hallo deutsch schule punkt ch hören und
nachsprechen lektion fünf hört zu und
spricht nach was ist das was ist das das
ist ein buch das ist ein buch ist das
eine lampe ist das eine lampe
nein das ist keine lampe nein das ist
keine lampe das ist ein glas das ist ein
glas ist das ein bett ist das ein bett
nein das ist kein bett nein das ist kein
bett
ist ein sofa das ist ein sofa wer ist
das wer ist das das ist nicole das ist
nicole sie kommt aus lausanne
sie kommt aus lausanne ist das dein
freund ist das dein freund
nein das ist nicht mein freund
nein das ist nicht mein freund hast du
eine freundin hat
eine freundin nein ich habe keine
freundin
nein ich habe keine freundin haben sie
kinder haben sie kinder
[Musik]
nein ich habe keine kinder
nein ich habe keine kinder ich habe eine
tochter
[Musik]
ja ich habe eine tochter
sprechen sie bitte langsam sprechen sie
bitte langsam
was bedeutet postleitzahl was bedeutet
postleitzahl
wie schreibt man das wie
schreibt man das kannst du das bitte
buchstabieren kann
und das bitte buchstabieren können sie
das bitte buchstabieren können sie das
bitte buchstabieren
ich verstehe kein schweizerdeutsch
sprechen sie bitte hochdeutsch sprechen
sie bitte hochdeutsch
kannst du das bitte wiederholen
kannst du das bitte wiederholen können
sie das bitte wiederholen können sie das
bitte wiederholen
hier ist ein schlüssel
hier ist ein schlüssel ist das dein
schlüssel ist das dein schlüssel
nein das ist nicht mein schlüssel
nein das ist nicht mein schlüssel welche
farbe hat der schlüssel welche farbe hat
der schlüssel
er ist blau
hier ist eine jacke hier ist eine jacke
ist das deine jacke ist das deine jacke
nein das ist nicht meine jacke
nein das ist nicht meine jacke welche
farbe hat die jacke welche
farbe hat die jacke sie ist rot sie ist
rot hier
ein handy hier ist ein handy ist das
dein handy ist das dein handy nein das
ist nicht mein handy nein das ist nicht
mein handy welche farbe hat das handy
welche farbe hat das handy es ist
schwarz es ist schwarz
grün grün siehst das buch die bücher das
buch die bücher der schüler die schüler
der schüler die schüler der stuhl die
stühle der stuhl die stühle
märz märz später später das land die
länder das land die länder der vater die
väter der vater die väter das blatt die
blätter das blatt die blätter 12.12
hören hören
der sohn die söhne der sohn die söhne
die tochter die töchter die
tochter die töchter das wort die wörter
das wort die wörter
[Musik]